NOW BACK TO "HANNITY."
>> Sean: RIGHT NOW, FOR MORE
REACTION ON TONIGHT'S BIG
BREAKING NEWS THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL HOROWITZ HAS SUBMITTED
HIS FISA REPORT FOR
CLASSIFICATION REVIEW TO THE
DOJ, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR FORMER
CONGRESSMAN TREY GOWDY.
YOU FIRST SAID -- AND I'LL GET
TO THIS IN A SECOND, THAT THE
IDEA THAT NOW McCABE, THEY
PASSED ON ANY SPECIAL TREATMENT,
BUT IT WAS A WHILE AGO THAT
REPORT IDENTIFIED THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT IDENTIFIED HIM AS
A LIAR AND A LEAKER.
AND YOU SAID IT'S A CELEBRATION
OF OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
NOW, WE HAVE THE SECOND MINOR
REPORT.
THAT WAS COMEY LACKING CANDOR.
BUT THAT DIDN'T RESULT IN --
WELL, IT DID RESULT IN A
REFERRAL, BUT IT DID SEEM LIKE
THEY'RE MOVING FORWARD.
WHY IS THIS TAKING SO LONG.
WE'LL GET TO FISA NEXT.
BECAUSE I HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT THE OUTCOME WILL BE.
>> UH YOU KNOW, SEAN, THERE WAS
A TRIAL IN DC, WHAT, LAST WEEK?
AND FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNCIL
GREG CRAIG WAS FOUND NOT GUILTY
IN WHAT WAS A REALLY QUICK JURY
VERDICT.
THESE ARE TOUGH CASES.
IT IS HARDER THAN IT MIGHT
APPEAR TO CONVINCE 12 PEOPLE OF
ANYTHING.
I USED TO HAVE TO DO IT FOR A
LIVING.
IT'S TOUGH.
YOU HAVE TO DOT EVERY I AND
CROSS EVERY T, IT'S MORE
DIFFICULT IF IT'S A HIGH-PROFILE
DEFENDANT.
SO IF THEY GO FORWARD WITH
McCABE, YOU CAN REST-ASSURED,
THAT'S GOING TO BE A TOUGH
TRIAL.
WE DON'T WANT THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT GOING TRIAL AND
LOSING.
THEY LOST TO GREG CRAIG.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO TRIAL,
YOU NEED TO WIN.
>> Sean: YOU NEVER LOST A CASE
AS A PROSECUTOR.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE SO GOOD AT
WHAT YOU DO.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
WE NOW KNOW -- I CAN GIVE YOU --
AS IT RELATES TO FISA AND THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT, I KNOW
OF THREE SEPARATE TIME,
INCLUDING, BY THE WAY, THE UK
MEMO WARNING ABOUT STEELE'S
CREDIBILITY.
WE KNOW THREE SEPARATE INSTANCES
BEFORE THE FISA WAS SIGNED, THE
BULK OF INFORMATION WE NOW KNOW
IS THE UNVERIFIED DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER, LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION ACCORDING TO THE
NEW YORK TIMES FROM THE GET-GO,
BUT THEY WERE WARNED ABOUT
STEELE'S CREDIBILITY BEFORE THEY
SIGNED THE FIRST FISA.
THEY WERE WARNED BY BRUCE SWORD.
THE UK WAS WARNING ABOUT HIS
CREDIBILITY.
THAT STEELE HAD AN AGENDA, IT
WASN'T VERIFIED.
AND HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
THEY USED IT ANYWAY.
NOW WE KNOW IT'S UNVERIFIABLE,
BECAUSE STEELE NEVER STOOD BY
HIS OWN DOSSIER AND UNDER OATH
SAID I HAVE NO IDEA IF ANY OF IT
IS TRUE.
TO ME, THAT SEEMS LIKE
PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON FISA
COURT.
WHEN YOU COUPLE THAT WITH ANDREW
McCABE, THE DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
SAYING NO FISA WARRANT, THAT
MAKES ME THINK THEY DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE PRESENTING
TO THE COURT.
AND THAT WAS A FRAUD AND THEY
KNEW IT WAS A FRAUD, BUT THEY
SAID IT WAS VERIFIED AND IT
WASN'T.
>> LET'S ASSUME FOR THE SAKE OF
ARGUMENT THAT EVERYTHING YOU SAY
IS TRUE.
LET'S ASSUME THAT.
YOU STILL HAVE TO FIND A FEDERAL
STATUTE IF YOUR OBJECTIVE IS
INDICTMENT.
I'M VERY CLEAR EVERY TIME YOU'RE
GOOD ENOUGH TO HAVE ME ON, WE
CANNOT HAVE A SOCIETY WHERE
INDICTMENT IS THE ONLY THING
THAT CARRIES WITH IT ANY STIGMA.
MOST OF THE NAMES INVOLVED IN
THE 2016 HAVE BEEN FIRED OR
PUBLICLY CALLED TO TASK.
KEEP IN MIND, JIM COMEY TWICE
NOW, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL SAID
YOU DID NOT MEET OUR
EXPECTATIONS.
YOU FAILED TO FOLLOW POLICY.
YOU VIOLATED YOUR EMPLOYEE
AGREEMENT.
ALL OF THAT HAS TO BE
SIGNIFICANT.
LOOK, I USED TO MAKE
REPRESENTATIONS IN FRONT OF THE
COURT.
I TRIED TO BE HONEST AND FAIR
ABOUT IT.
BUT LET'S ASSUME I DIDN'T TELL
THE COURT SOMETHING.
THE REMEDY FOR ME IS NOT
INDICTMENT, THE REMEDY IS I MAY
LOSE MY LAW LICENSE.
THE REMEDY IS THE COURT MAY HOLD
ME IN CONTEMPT.
>> HERE'S THE THING.
IF I AM WARNED SOMETHING THAT
I'M ABOUT TO PRESENT IN COURT IS
FALSE AND AT THE TOP OF AN
APPLICATION OF MAKING IT TO THE
COURT, IT SAYS VERIFIED.
I TEST IT.
I SIGN IT, SAY IT'S VERIFIED AND
I'M WARNED THAT IT ISN'T.
WHEN THE FBI GOT INTO THEIR
SPREAD SHEET, THEY DISCOVERED
95% OF THE DIRTY DOSSIER WAS UP
TRUE.
THAT'S LATER, THOUGH.
IF I KNOW --
>> IF IT'S ON A SPREAD SHEET.
>> IF I KNOW IT'S NOT VERIFIED
AND I PRESENT IT AS VERIFIED AND
IT'S UNVERIFIABLE, THAT WOULD
SEEM LIKE SEAN HANNITY WENT TO
THE COURT AND COMMITTED A FRAUD
IN THE COURT CONSCIOUSLY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ACHIEVING A POLITICAL
AGENDA.
WHY DO I THINK TREY GAODY, AS
GREAT AN ATTORNEY AS YOU ARE,
NEVER LOST A CASE AS A
PROSECUTOR, THAT I WOULD GO TO
JAIL?
>> IF YOU'RE A LAWYER, YOU CAN
LOSE YOUR LAW LICENSE.
THE COURT CAN HOLD YOU IN
CONTEMPT.
>> Sean: IF YOU LIE BEFORE A
JUDGE?
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LYING BEFORE
A JUDGE.
>> YOU'LL BE HELD IN CONTEMPT OF
COURT.
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU CAN GO TO JAIL FOR THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT LAWYERS WHO
MAKE FACTUAL MISREPRESENTATIONS
IN FRONT OF JUDGES WIND UP
GETTING INDICTED.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET PUNISHED.
YOU'RE GOING BE HELD IN
CONTEMPT.
YOU MAY BE GET SENT TO PRISON.
LOOK -- I'M NOT MINIMIZING
ANYTHING OF WHAT THEY'VE DONE.
WE'VE GOT TO ASK THE RIGHT
PUNISHMENT TO THE RIGHT OFFENSE.
>> Sean: BUT YOU'RE DENYING BY
SIGNING THAT AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
YOU'RE LITERALLY USING THAT LIE
TO SPY ON A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN AND TRANSITION.
>> WE IDENTIFIED THE STATUTE,
USING THE COLOR OF A GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL, IT COULD BE A 1983
ACTION.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
WE HAVE TO MATCH UP THE CONDUCT
WITH A SPECIFIC CODE VIOLATION.
>> REGULARLY --
>> WITH AN VIOLATION.
NOW WE'RE GETTING SOMEWHERE.
>> I'LL SEND YOU GREG JARRETT'S
LIST.
HE'S IDENTIFIED A WHOLE VARIETY
OF CRIMES PERPETRATING A FRAUD
ON THE COURT.
>> DON'T SEND IT TO ME, SEND IT
TO BILL BARR.
NOTHING I CAN DO ABOUT IT RIGHT
NOW.
>> DO YOU HAVE HIS E-MAIL.
I DON'T KNOW BILL BARR.